mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
s'il vous plaît
maintenant que la rapporteur général est
arrivé
voilà s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
monsieur Savary s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît voilà
les 9h03 on va commencer parce que on a
un petit programme ce matin
donc mes chers collègues
nous recevons ce matin la Cour des
comptes représentée par Madame Véronique
à maillon président de la sixième
chambre
messieurs Nicolas fourrier conseiller
maître Jean-Luc fullachier conseiller
maître et Thibault Perrin conseillé
référendaire afin qu'il nous présente le
rapport de la Cour sur l'application des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat qui sera ensuite disponible en
vidéo à la demande
l'audition de ce matin est
traditionnelle puisque nous entendons
chaque année la Cour des comptes afin
qu'elle nous présente le Ralph SS
oh là là elle revêt toutefois un
caractère particulier notamment en
termes de calendrier puisque c'est la
première fois que s'applique les
nouvelles dispositions organiques au
terme desquelles chaque année la Cour
des comptes établit un rapport sur
l'application des lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale
conjoint au dépôt du projet de loi
d'approbation des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale vous pourrez d'ailleurs nous
préciser le cas échéant les conséquences
que ce nouveau calendrier a pu avoir sur
votre travaux c'est donc afin d'aider la
Commission à force à former son jugement
sur le projet de loi d'approbation des
comptes que nous vous entendons jugement
qui désormais fera l'objet d'un vote et
la semaine prochaine en commission et le
3 juillet en sciences publiques
à cet égard même si cela dépasse le
cadre de votre rapport nous ne pouvons
qu'être interpellé par le refus de
certification des comptes d'une branche
de la sécurité sociale par la Cour cette
année encore
madame la Présidente je vais sans plus
attendre vous laisser nous présenter
leur ralphese la rapporteur général les
rapporteurs de branches et les
commissaires qui le souhaiteront pour
ensuite vous interroger madame la
Présidente c'est à vous
alors merci madame la présidente
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs de branches mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs et sénatrices je
vous remercie de votre invitation à vous
présenter donc le rapport sur la
certification des contes de la sécurité
sociale et le rapport sur l'application
des lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale je viens vous les présenter donc
avec Jean-Luc fullassier qui est le
président de la première section de la
sixième chambre Nicolas fourrier avec
notre rapporteur général et Thibault
Perrin le rapporteur général adjoint ce
rapport est établi comme chaque année
dans le cadre de la mission
constitutionnelle de la Cour des comptes
au Parlement mais c'est une grande
première
ce rapport s'accompagne désormais
accompagne désormais pardon le projet de
loi d'approbation des contes de la
sécurité sociale équivalent de la loi de
règlement pour l'État qui a été présenté
pour la première fois cette année
discuter au Parlement du Range juin et
il n'accompagne donc plus le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
au mois de septembre comme c'était le
cas précédemment c'est une avancée
importante de gouvernance des finances
sociales que la Cour a souhaité et nous
nous réjouissons que le Parlement est à
connaître spécifiquement
de l'exécution des recettes et des
dépenses comme moment d'évaluation et de
bilan des politiques publiques conduites
par la Sécurité Sociale ce rapport reste
un exercice annuel traditionnel pour la
cour il intervient toutefois dans un
contexte un peu particulier à plus d'un
titre avec d'une part la déclaration de
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé sur
la fin d'urgence sanitaire pour la
pandémie de covid-19 d'autre part avec
l'affaiblissement sensible de la
croissance en raison du choc d'inflation
et des conséquences de l'invasion russe
en Ukraine
avec plus généralement une très grande
incertitude sur l'évolution des
paramètres macroéconomiques la première
partie durale analyse les comptes 2022
la sécurité sociale et leur perspective
pour les années à venir ceci resteront
durablement dégradés malgré une
amélioration temporaire en 2023 un
effort de redressement durable des
finances de la sécurité sociale nous
apparaît donc nécessaire sans lui nous
n'aurions aucune marge de manœuvre pour
investir dans l'avenir nous devrons
également faire face au coût associés à
l'augmentation rapide ces prochaines
années du nombre de personnes âgées
dépendantes
dans des conditions leur permettant de
vivre dignement et il est nécessaire
enfin de ne pas transférer aux
générations futures le financement de
nos dépenses courantes cette
responsabilité collective se contrat
entre les générations nous obligent nous
devons donc être très attentifs à la
qualité de la dépense sociale comme
d'ailleurs à la qualité de toutes
dépenses publiques le Ralph que je vous
présente aujourd'hui trace des pistes
pour améliorer l'utilité la valeur
ajoutée l'efficacité des dépenses de
sécurité sociale bref le service rendu à
nos concitoyens il fournit plusieurs
illustrations de ce qui pourrait être
amélioré à travers un bilan des mesures
ou des réformes portées par les récentes
financement de la sécurité sociale que
vous avez voté
c'est la deuxième partie du rapport et
nous intéressons également à des
domaines ou des sujets qui n'ont pas à
notre sens bénéficier d'une attention
suffisante c'est ces dernières années et
c'est la troisième partie du rapport la
première et pendant consacrée à la
situation financière de la sécurité
sociale ces deux préoccupations
financières et qualitatives sont ainsi
encore une fois encore cette année au
cœur de notre rapport plutôt que d'en
détailler successivement les différents
chapitres je voudrais en souligner les
cinq principaux enjeux le premier enjeu
après aux conditions de certification
des comptes des caisses et des branches
du régime général par la Cour des
comptes le deuxième à la situation
actuelle la situation financière
actuelle et future de la sécurité
sociale le troisième enjeu est lié à
notre
réforme à la réforme pardon de notre
système de santé le quatrième il y a
l'amélioration des services rendus aux
usagers ou aux assurés sociaux
depuis le cinquième concerne la lutte
contre la fraude concernant tout d'abord
les contes de la sécurité sociale
et leur certification nous souhaitons
attirer l'attention cette année sur
quatre points en premier lieu la
comparabilité des produits et du
résultat entre 2022 et 2021 n'est pas
assurée des produits de prélèvement
sociaux sur les travailleurs
indépendants qui auraient dû être
comptabilisés en 2020 l'ont été en 2021
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement pour 2023 le Parlement
contre la vie du gouvernement a pris en
compte la correction demandée par la
Cour et à en conséquence approuvé pour
2021 un montant de recettes de 5
milliards d'euros inférieurs à celui
ressortant des comptes approuvés par les
branches du régime général les
organismes nationaux du régime général
et leur tutelle ont toutefois refusé
d'établir
des comptes pro formats de l'exercice
2021 que la Cour avait demandé seule une
information ponctuelle a été apportée
dans l'annexe aux comptes il y a donc un
écart de 5 milliards d'euros entre les
comptes 2021 tel qu'a prouvé par les
Caisses nationales de sécurité sociale
et les tableaux d'équilibre tels qu'a
prouvés par le Parlement
en deuxième lieu nous avons refusé de
certifier les comptes 2022 de la branche
famille en raison des insuffisances du
contrôle interne de cette branche en
effet les erreurs qui affectent les
prestations 9 mois après leur mise en
paiement représente près d'un quart des
montants versés au titre des primes
d'activité près d'un sixième des
montants versés au titre du RSA et près
d'un huitième des aides au logement de
surcroît l'indicateur de risque
financier résiduel à 24 mois indique que
les rappels et les indus qui ne seront
jamais corrigés Ce monta 5,8 milliards
d'euros ce montant a doublé en seulement
4 ans la CNAV met en oeuvre des
contrôles insuffisants et ne sait pas
doté d'une stratégie de redressement à
court terme c'est l'ensemble de ces
éléments qui nous a poussé à refuser de
certifier je précise que ça n'est pas la
première fois que la Cour refuse de
certifier
une une branche de la sécurité sociale
depuis 2006 date à laquelle nous est
laquelle nous exerçons cette mission en
troisième lieu la cour réitère c'est
critique sur l'absence de combinaison
des comptes de la branche vieillesse
avec ceux du Fonds de solidarité
vieillesse et sur l'absence d'engagement
orbilant pour les retraites futures
comme le fait par exemple l'État pour
les comptes de l'État en quatrième lieu
la gestion de l'indemnité inflation
exceptionnelle de 100 euros par par
foyer bénéficiaires par les organismes
de sécurité sociale et qui a généré 1,7
millions de doublons
sur 38 millions de bénéficiaires la
récupération des indus est quasi enfin
très incertaine ou quasi impossible
comme nous l'ont confirmé à la fois le
ministère des Finances et l'ensemble des
caisses de sécurité sociale et de leur
tutelle puisque
c'est l'absence la difficulté de
récupération est presque
consubstantielle à la manière dont a été
créé
et a été mise en place
cette indemnité inflation
l'ensemble des travaux de certification
des comptes de la Sécurité sociale ont
contribué à alimenter la première partie
du rap ce qui en est la partie
financière et que je vais vous présenter
maintenant
donc le déficit des régimes obligatoires
de base de la sécurité sociale s'établit
en 2022 à 19,6 milliards d'euros un
niveau très élevé il devrait s'améliorer
significativement en 2023 à 8,2
milliards d'euros sous l'effet à la fois
du reflux de la crise sanitaire et de la
vivre progression de la masse salariale
qui constitue comme vous le savez
l'assiette principale des recettes de la
sécurité sociale cette tendance
favorable devrait toutefois
s'interrompre dès 2024 et le déficit de
la Sécurité sociale recommençait à
augmenter en effet si la réforme des
retraites promulguée en avril 2023
dernier aura des effets favorables sur
les soldes de la branche vieillesse il
est avéré qu'elle ne devrait pas
permettre à elle seule de les rétablir à
l'horizon 2030 le régime général est
plus encore celui géré par la CNRACL
Caisse nationale de retraite des agents
des collectivités locales pour les
agents de la fonction publique locale la
fonction publique hospitalière
resterait structurellement déficitaire
dans ces conditions la question du
financement des déficits sociaux se
posera des exercices 2024 la cosse ne
sera pas en mesure de prendre en charge
ces déficits et la caisse
d'amortissement de la société sociale
pardon la Cadès ne pourrait le faire
qu'au prix d'une nouvelle prolongation
de sa durée au-delà de 2033 et dont la
contrepartie si elle était décidée
devrait être nous semble-t-il un
programme de réforme
le respect de la trajectoire prévue de
dépense suppose en outre
que l'objectif assigné aux dépenses
d'assurance maladie l'ONDAM soit
respectée
or les dépenses d'assurance maladie
progressent à vive allure depuis 2021
pardon en raison des charges
exceptionnelles liées à la crise
sanitaire et des mesures salariales
décidaient dans le cadre du Ségur de la
santé mais aussi comme le montre le
graphique que vous avez à l'écran du
fait d'une croissance forte de la
dépense notamment pour les indemnités
journalières et pour les produits de
santé j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
l'objectif 2023 est la prévision pour
les années ultérieurs marque la volonté
des pouvoirs publics de donner un coup
d’arrêt à cette progression avec une
hypothèse de progression de Londres
particulièrement volontariste inférieur
à la prévision d'inflation de 2023 et
toutefois il ne suffit pas d'affirmer un
objectif pour que celui-ci soit atteint
et nous recommandons que des mesures
correctrices soit déclenchées en cas de
dérapage quel que soit la cause et que
des dispositifs de régulation soient
mises en oeuvre pour l'ensemble des
secteurs qui n'en disposent pas encore
notamment pour les soins de ville et
pour les indemnités journalières
un point de fragilité particulier et
celui de l'évolution des déficits de la
dette de l'hôpital public qui n'entre
pas dans le champ de London la loi
organique du 14 mars 2022 a créé une
nouvelle annexe aux lois de financement
de la sécurité sociale
qui doit permettre de s'assurer que les
recettes des hôpitaux sont suffisantes
pour leur permettre d'investir dans leur
modernisation sans augmenter leur dette
pour permettre ainsi un réel suivi la
situation financière des établissements
de santé nous recommandons d'accélérer
le calendrier de versement des dotations
de fin d'exercice vos hôpitaux publics
actuellement elles sont versées à la
mi-mars de l'année suivante et
d'accélérer le calendrier
d'établissements de leur compte
actuellement bouclés en juillet de
l'année suivante il faut aussi
homogénéiser les informations
financières entre chaque catégorie
d'établissements hôpitaux publics et
clinique privée à but lucratif ou non
j'en viens maintenant au troisième enjeu
central pour l'avenir de l'assurance
maladie celui de l'efficience de notre
système de santé et notamment des soins
de ville ce chantier doit être envisagé
avec beaucoup de clarté de détermination
et surtout de constance dans le temps
nous l'illustrons à travers trois
exemples portant sur les
expérimentations engagées au titre de
l'article 51 de la LSS 2018 sur la
situation des samuds et enfin sur les
actions dites de maîtrise médicalisée
des dépenses de santé
tout d'abord nous avons examiné le cadre
dans lequel quelques 120
expérimentations ont été engagées depuis
2018 pour tester de nouveaux modes de
tarification et d'organisation des soins
la cour est pleinement consciente que
réformée notre système de santé n'est
pas chose simple
l'expérimentation est utile pour mieux
adapter la réforme aux besoins mais
aussi pour démontrer par exemple
par l'exemple pardon en permettant
professionnel de santé de s'approprier
de nouveaux modes de travail plus
collaboratifs plus coordonnées mais nous
constatons que jusqu'ici rien n'a été
fait pour préparer la généralisation de
ces expérimentations la Cour rappelle
par conséquent que lorsque des doutes
sont levés sur l'utilité de certaines
évolutions il est impératif de mettre en
oeuvre ses dispositifs dès que possible
la technique de l'expérimentation ne
doit en effet pas devenir un moyen
dilatoire pour repousser davantage
l'engagement de réforme utile à nos
concitoyens qui permettent des soins
plus efficace de meilleure qualité et
plus économe de ressources de
l'assurance maladie nous avons souhaité
également examiner la situation de la
régulation médicale autour des samues et
des murs et de nouveaux concepts des
services d'accès aux soins les SAS qui
sont censés apporter une solution aux
demandes de soins restés sans réponse de
la médecine de ville nous constatons que
depuis 2014 le nombre d'appels reçus par
les SAMU augmenter de 22% dans le même
temps du fait d'un rattrapage que nous
estimons nécessaires
puis du fait de la création des SAS le
coût total des dispositifs concourants
au fonctionnement de la régulation
médicale a augmenté de 46% entre 2016 et
2022 augmentation qui pourrait même
atteindre 62% en 2023 s'il est normal
que les samues bénéficient d'un
rattrapage de moyens le succès des
investissements dans les services
d'accès aux soins dépendra de la
capacité de la médecine libérale à se
mobiliser et à s'organiser afin que
toute personne ayant besoin d'être
examinée par un généraliste en ville
puisse bénéficier d'une consultation
dans les 48 heures la course sera très
attentive à ce que cet objectif fixé au
sas soit mesurée et atteint
enfin la cour aura l'occasion dans le
cadre de l'exercice de revue des
dépenses publiques de revenir fin juin
au début juillet sur les enjeux
déficiences des soins de ville qui
représentent comme vous le savez le
premier poste de dépenses d'assurance
maladie 45 % de l'objectif national
en attendant nous avons porté un regard
critique sur les économies figurants
chaque année en annexe au PLFSS au titre
de ce qui est appelé communément la
maîtrise médicalisée nous avons démontré
le caractère artificiel des économies
présentées et notre démonstration n'est
pas contestée ni par l'administration ni
par l'assurance maladie
en août force et de constater que les
actions conduites jusqu'ici par
l'Assurance Maladie pour rendre plus
efficiente les dépenses de prescription
des médecins de ville n'ont pas été
efficaces si l'on n'en juge par la
consommation de médicaments génériques
la France reste dans une situation peu
favorable par rapport à ses voisins
notamment par rapport à l'Allemagne
puisque la consommation de génériques et
deux fois plus faible en France qu'en
Allemagne j'en arrive maintenant à notre
quatrième enjeu celui de la qualité du
service rendu aux usagers
nous l'illustrons par quatre exemples
qui montrent à des degrés divers
l'importance des efforts à consentir
pour justifier de l'usage pertinent des
sommes considérables mises dans notre
système de sécurité sociale tout d'abord
nous nous sommes intéressés à l'objectif
de parité des pensions servies aux
hommes et aux femmes prévues par le code
de la sécurité sociale il est loin
d'être atteint les femmes perçoivent en
moyenne une pension de retraite pardon
inférieure de 28% à celle des hommes en
mais l'écart de pension hors réversion
est plus importante encore il est égal à
40%
. sans les dispositifs de solidarité
la pension moyenne de droit direct des
femmes serait inférieures de 50% à celle
des hommes ces écarts importants ne
seront pas substantiellement modifiés
par la réforme des retraites
50 milliards sont environ dépensés
chaque année à travers des mécanismes
complexes des droits familiaux de
retraite et des dispositifs de réversion
nous sommes convaincus que la remise à
plat de ces mécanismes permettrait de
les rendre plus efficaces à moindre coût
pour la collectivité
nous avons examiné également les règles
et la gestion de l'indemnisation des
congés maternités et paternité nous
constatons les limites des politiques
d'alignement des règles applicables au
non salarié sur celles applicables aux
assurés salariés en effet même des
droits désormais quasi identiques
les indépendantes et les exploitantes
agricoles prennent moins de jours de
congés maternité que les salariés par
ailleurs nous constatons que la gestion
des indemnités par les caisses de
sécurité sociale et d'une qualité très
insuffisante avec des délais de
versement anormalement longs ce qui
pénalise les assurés concernés
le caractère perfectible de la gestion
de la sécurité sociale apparaît aussi à
travers les litiges opposant les assurés
et les organismes de sécurité sociale
chaque année les assurés sociaux
déposent près de 70 000 recours devant
les tribunaux plus de 100000 dossiers
sont auparavant soumis aux instances
pré-contentieuses des caisses de
sécurité sociale
nous soulignons qu'une intervention
accrue des médiateurs doit être favorisé
pour éviter que les litiges ne se
terminent devant les tribunaux les
simplifications sont aussi à apporter
pour éviter que les assurés soient
contraints dans certains cas à saisir
deux juges différents pour les mêmes
motifs et on pense en particulier à la
carte mobilité inclusion
qui relève soit du tribunal
administratif soit du tribunal
judiciaire selon qu'elle est une carte
mobilité inclusion stationnement ou pas
ces enjeux sur ces enjeux d'efficacité
et de qualité du service public nous
avons enfin souhaité donner un coup de
projecteur sur le régime social des
marins
et les difficultés majeures qu'il
rencontre depuis plusieurs années les
conditions d'une gestion efficace de la
sécurité sociale ne sont pas garanties
une évolution en profondeur de ce régime
est indispensable pour finir j'en viens
maintenant au cinquième et dernier enjeu
celui de la lutte contre les fraudes aux
prestations sociales c'est un sujet qui
ne laisse personne indifférent et qui
est au cœur du plan de lutte contre les
fraudes au finances publiques dévoiler
des bumets par le gouvernement au-delà
des dommages financiers considérables
qu'elle entraîne la fraude aux
prestation sociale constitue une
atteinte au principe de solidarité donc
au pacte républicains qui fonde depuis
1945 la sécurité sociale la lutte contre
la fraude est donc à la fois un
impératif d'efficacité économique mais
aussi de justice sociale
nous avons une idée qui se précise du
coup de la fraude aux prestations
probablement de l'ordre de 6 à 8
milliards d'euros
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup trop
encore cette fourchette ne tient-elle
pas compte des erreurs fautives des
assurés dont l'intention frauduleuse ne
peut être prouvée oui nous parlons bien
de la fraude au prestation et non pas de
la photo cotisation d'Afro de cotisation
l'administration et les caisses de
sécurité sociale ont la volonté d'agir
nous l'avons constaté et nous avons
constaté des progrès mais trop peu de
moyens sont consacrés au contrôle la
coopération entre administration pour
échanger les données de progresse pas
assez vite les fraudeurs ne sont pas
sanctionnés de façon suffisamment ferme
ni systématique la lutte contre l'afro
doit donc devenir une priorité de tout
premier plan qui oblige responsable et
gestionnaires de la sécurité sociale
mais aussi l'ensemble des assurés
sociaux
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
me tiens avec les magistrats qui
m'accompagnent à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci madame la
Présidente et je laisse tout de suite la
parole à la rapporteur général
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
tout d'abord vous exprimer ma gratitude
madame la Présidente de la sixième
chambre de la Cour des comptes ainsi
qu'à l'ensemble de ceux qui vous
entourent aujourd'hui et ceux qui sont
aussi avec vous au quotidien en tout cas
moi j'invite ceux qui ne l'ont pas
encore fait à regarder précisément votre
rapport parce qu'on y trouve vraiment
une mine d'informations et notamment
vous avez parlé des de la retraite des
marins mais tout ce qui concerne la
fraude aussi et qui
abat quelques fausses idées que l'on
peut se faire sur une une fraude énorme
et qui ne serait pas qui ne serait pas
en tout cas poursuivi parce que vous
l'avez dit il faut absolument être
comment dirais-je dans la sanction en
tout cas rechercher la cause de la
fraude mais il faut aussi se rendre à
l'évidence il y a des légendes qui
circulent et ça il faut absolument aussi
les combattre donc merci pour l'ensemble
de ce rapport mais des questions sur
d'abord la certification des comptes
vous l'avez dit madame la Présidente
vous avez refusé de certifier les
comptes 2022 de la branche famille nous
avons eu l'occasion hier pour certains
d'entre nous d'écouter le directeur de
la CNAV qui a pu apporter des précisions
et notamment
des éléments sur sa réaction et semblait
pas tellement étonné finalement de cette
non certification
et donc nous avons eu de son côté
quelques explications des assurances
obtenues depuis comme le plan de lutte
contre la fraude annoncée par le
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics le 30 mai 2023 vous
semble-t-elle susceptible justement de
répondre
à ce refus de certification des comptes
de la branche famille
dans le cas des contes 2021 la Cour des
comptes a refusé de certifier ceux de
l'activité du recouvrement et vous avez
démarré par cette question notamment sur
les 5 milliards d'euros qui a été
imputés sur 2021 au lieu de 2020 au
Sénat nous avions eu l'occasion lors du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale également de faire état
de cette peut-être pas dire un sincérité
mais en tout cas une mauvaise
affectation et nous avions souhaité que
les tableaux d'équilibre soient corrigés
il n'en a pas été le cas et vous
indiquez dans dans votre rapport de
certification des comptes 2022 que vous
avez demandé au casse d'établir dans le
cadre des contes 2022 des comptes pro
formats de l'exercice 2021 prenant en
compte cette correction ce que les
caisses en fait vous ont refusé on peut
trouver surprenant que les caisses
persistent à retenir des montants la
cour et le Parlement en son temps avec
considéré erroné est-ce que vous avez
plus d'explications à nous donner
les questions sur le rapport
d'approbation de la loi de financement
de sécurité sociale la recommandation de
du Ralph 2023 et de renforcer la
traçabilité et revoir les modalités
d'établissement de validation de
formalisation et d'explication des
retraites opérés pour la production des
tableaux d'équilibre afin de permettre à
la cour de communiquer au Parlement ses
avis sur leur cohérence au moment du
dépôt du projet de loi d'approbation des
comptes de la Sécurité sociale
pouvez-vous nous rappeler les principaux
retraitements qui ont été opérés pour
passer des comptes des différentes
branches soumis à la certification de la
cour au tableau d'équilibre et puis
désormais aux plaques nous indiquer
s'agissant des retraitements les
principales informations dont vous
disposez et celles qui vous manque
la recommandation 3 du Ralph consiste
notamment pour permettre à la cour de
produire ses avis sur les tableaux
d'équilibre et le tableau patrimonial du
Plax dans de bonnes conditions à avancer
de 15 jours la date de production des
comptes et à réunir la Commission des
comptes de la Sécurité sociale la
première quinzaine de mai et ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer où en sont vos
échanges avec le gouvernement à ce sujet
enfin le chapitre sur la lutte contre la
fraude aux prestations ne semblent pas
comprendre de chiffrage global de
celle-ci même s'il est possible en
combinant le tableau page 233 avec
l'extrapolation faite dans le texte dans
le cas de la CNAM qui n'achiffré
d'ailleurs la faute que dans 6 domaines
de parvenir à une fourchette entre 6 et
8 milliards d'euros c'est ce que vous
nous avez dit c'est ce qu'il y a aussi
été rappelé hier dans nos auditions avec
de fait le premier président de la Cour
des comptes indiqués dans sa
présentation du rapport à la presse que
le coût de l'afro de prestation était
probablement donc ce terme est toujours
un peu
comment perturbant on va dire cette
estimation vous semble-t-elle pouvoir
significativement évolué avec par
exemple la finalisation des estimations
de la CNAM ou des estimations plus fines
dans le cas des retraites je vous
remercie
je vous laisse répondre d'abord et
ensuite il y aura les questions des
rapporteurs de branches
merci beaucoup
madame la rapporteur général alors votre
première question porte sur le refus de
certification de la branche famille
alors je précise que nous avons déjà
refusé de certifier les comptes de la
branche famille en 2011 donc ça n'est
pas une première je veux dire pour la
branche famille et nous avions vu à
l'époque les résultats assez rapidement
de ce refus de certification
c'est-à-dire une une remise en ordre de
la gestion et des comptes de la branche
famille et notamment sur la précision
des indicateurs de risque résiduel
la branche famille étant devenue
quelques pendant un certain nombre
d'années le bon élève j'allais dire de
la classe parmi les autres caisses de
sécurité sociale et puis les choses sont
ce sont dégradées nous avions déjà
alerté l'année dernière au moment de la
certification des comptes sur le risque
sur les dérapages à la dégradation de ce
risque
financier et de ses indicateurs de
risque fin résiduelle sans avoir été
entendu et donc cette année il y a trois
éléments qui nous ont conduits à ne pas
certifier d'une part la dégradation des
liquidations erronées pour un montant
extrêmement important que j'ai raté tout
à l'heure de 5 milliards 8
d'erreur non corrigées au bout de 24
mois et qui ne seront jamais récupérés
donc on arrive à des niveaux quand même
que le saut la deuxième raison c'est que
les la branche à maintenu le niveau de
ses contrôles à un niveau inférieur à ce
qu'il était en 2019
et le troisième élément c'est que il n'y
a pas de perspective d'amélioration de
la qualité des liquidations à court
terme donc la branche ne trace pas de
perspective d'amélioration ne nous a pas
présenté un plan pour essayer de
remédier à ces mauvais résultats et donc
on ne sentait pas une prise de
conscience de la part de la branche pour
essayer de se remettre en ordre
donc la question des résultats des
risques et là mais la question des des
contrôles et de l'absence de perspective
de d'amélioration des contrôles à peser
aussi dans la décision de la cour de ne
pas certifier
je rappelle juste pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de d'ambiguïté que les les
erreurs que nous constatons les 5
milliards 8 portent à la fois sur des
indus et des rappels les indus
constituants 80% de ce montant et les
rappels c'est-à-dire des prestations qui
auraient dû être versées qui n'ont pas
été versées
représentent environ 20% de ce montant
sur
le
l'écart oui entre les tableaux
d'équilibre et les comptes
alors
je vais pas répondre à la place des
caisses de sécurité sociale et je serais
bien en peine de vous dire les raisons
pour lesquelles elles ont refusé de nous
établir des comptes proforma que par
ailleurs elles établissent pour d'autres
pour d'autres raisons quand il a
nécessité d'en faire
ce qui est certain c'est que nous
avons alerté tout de même les caisses
sur
d'abord cet écart qui rend les choses
inexplicables et le fait que cet écart a
été entériné par le Parlement et que le
Parlement selon nous a le dernier mot
elle n'est pas la vie des caisses mais
si vous les avez auditionnés si vous
avez auditionné à Monsieur amgard et
Lacoste peut-être que vous avez des
informations de première main
[Musique]
lacos a tendance à considérer
et puis le la DSS également qu'il s'agit
d'un problème norme comptable en réalité
le problème est plus large que celui-là
et alors nous attirons l'attention et je
me permets solennellement de d'attirer
votre attention mais je pense que c'est
inutile et vous êtes vous êtes alerté
là-dessus que les choses ont changé
puisque dorénavant c'est il appartient
au Parlement d'approuver
puisqu'elle loi d'approbation des contes
de la sécurité sociale donc nous avons
également attiré l'attention de
l'administration et des caisses de
sécurité sociale sur ce point
fondamental qui change par rapport à la
situation et santé parce que pour nos 5
milliards bon maintenant c'est du passé
mais si le cas se reproduisait à
l'avenir d'une différence entre les
tableaux d'équilibre et les contes de la
sécurité sociale la question me
semble-t-il ne pourrait pas être traitée
un petit peu par-dessus la jambe et
excusez-moi de cette expression un peu
triviale comme elle l'a été par les
caisses de sécurité sociale dès lors que
aujourd'hui il y a une loi d'approbation
des gants de la sécurité sociale il
revient donc bien au Parlement infini
d'approuver ses comptes donc il faudrait
très vigilant à l'avenir sur ces
questions là qui ne sont pas de simples
encore une fois question comptable
sur les retraitements entre
les retraitements
des tableaux d'équilibre par rapport au
compte alors d'abord une question de
périmètre ce n'est pas tout à fait le
même périmètre puisque la course
certifie les comptes du régime général
alors que les tableaux d'équilibre
portent sur l'ensemble des régimes de
base de la sécurité sociale ensuite
pour la plupart des régimes de base les
niveaux de charges et produits sont
retracés dans des tableaux centralisés
de données comptables mais pour certains
régimes comme celui des fonctionnaires
par exemple
on n'a pas ce plan comptable unique
et il n'établissent pas de tableaux
centraliser des données comptables donc
il faut arriver à agréger des données
qui ne sont pas présentées de la même
manière
et donc il y a tout ce travail de de
fait par la
[Musique]
par la
DSS pardon qui qui vise à voilà agréger
dans un format comparable des données
qui voilà viennent de plusieurs de
plusieurs sources sur selon des formats
disparates
ensuite la dssopèrent des des
contractions notamment pour
annuler le risque de double écriture
quand il y a des transferts entre régime
donc il y a un retraitement qui est
opéré par la DSS pour construire une
lecture consolidée des comptes alors je
sais pas si je vais tout détailler mais
voilà pour l'essentiel des retraitements
qui sont effectués et qui sont
nécessaires pour passer donc des comptes
bruts j'allais dire au tableau
d'équilibre
ensuite vous nous avez posé la question
du calendrier
oui calendrier qui
qui a été considérablement resserré avec
la le Plax ou la laxe et qui met la Cour
des comptes dans la situation
inconfortable d'avoir
enfin de recevoir des comptes le 15
avril
pour
les
certifiés et écrire le premier chapitre
durable sur la situation financière mais
surtout pour les certifiés on a
moins d'un mois moins d'un mois pour
voilà alors les travaux je vous rassure
quand même je vois l'inquiétude
peut-être de certains d'entre vous les
travaux de certification commencent en
réalité dès maintenant pour les contes
2023 qui sont présentés en 2024 donc les
équipes ont déjà commencé à travailler
avec l'ensemble des caisses pour mettre
au point les plans de contrôle pour
savoir bon donc on suit ça tout au long
de l'année c'est toute une équipe de
plus de 20 personnes qui consacrent
voilà tout son temps mais au moment de
la certification elle-même au moment de
l'arrêter des comptes les comptes sont
arrêtés le 15 mars mais nous nous les
avons avec les annexes et l'ensemble des
pièces annexes qui sont indispensables à
la lecture et à compréhension des
comptes finaux que le 15 avril et donc
il s'écoule à moi entre le 15 mars et le
15 avril et c'est ce délai que nous
aimerions voir raccourcir de manière à
nous permettre de travailler dans des
conditions un peu plus sereine
la DSS à qui nous sommes ouverts bien
sûr de cette de ces difficultés notre
souhait de voir raccourcir le calendrier
ne le souhaite pas et donc souhaite
rester sur sur les délais qui sont les
délaiss actuels
on n'est pas à l'abri d'un d'une
difficulté
l'année prochaine dans les années à
venir si vraiment ce calendrier
était maintenu
sur la lutte contre la fraude
alors
sur l'évaluation nous avons
effectivement et nous le disons
d'ailleurs dans le dans le Ralph fondé
notre évaluation sur une approche un peu
sommaire consistant à étendre par une
simple règle de trois les résultats
produit par la CNAM sur un périmètre
correspondant à peu près à 29% de son de
son portefeuille sur lequel ils ont fait
des
des sondages approfondis et avec une
idée assez sûre disons du montant de
fraude sur ces 29% du périmètre et donc
pour la CNAM nous avons étendu à nous
sommes partis du principe mais encore
une fois très grossier
que ce chiffre pouvait être étendu à
l'ensemble des prestations avec une
espèce de règle de trois qui nous permet
d'atteindre un montant qui
associer aux autres montants de fraude
estimés alors notamment par les équipes
de certification avec les indicateurs de
risque financiers résiduels pour les
autres branches nous permettent
d'arriver à ce chiffre de 6 à 8
milliards d'euros
une fois que la CNAM
qui représente presque la moitié quand
même de ces 6 à 8 milliards d'euros
enfin la fraude à la prestations
d'assurance maladie aura fait en détail
ce travail d'évaluation précise de la
fraude sur l'ensemble du périmètre de
ses prestations alors nous aurons une
idée plus précise des montants fraudés
ça peut être une mauvaise surprise avec
une fraude qui serait supérieure ça peut
être aussi une bonne surprise avec des
montants fraudés qui seraient inférieurs
il est très difficile une pour nous à ce
stade de le dire
ce dont se dont nous restons persuadés
c'est que les moyens
d'évoluent à la lutte contre l'afro de
sont insuffisants alors quand je dis
moyen pas seulement moyen humain il y a
bien sûr des moyens humains qui peuvent
être redéployés pour renforcer les
équipes de contrôle
dédiés à la lutte contre la fraude mais
également et c'est très important des
moyens informatiques c'est-à-dire que en
particulier concernant l'assurance
maladie il n'y a pas suffisamment et
nous l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises à
chaque fois que nous traitons de cette
question de la fraude aux prestations
d'assurance maladie il n'y a pas
suffisamment de système autobloquant
embarqués dans les systèmes
d'information de la CNAM qui permettrait
de déceler avant même que les
prestations ne soient servies à certains
nombre de possibilités d'incohérence
d'actes entre eux etc et nous attendons
beaucoup du nouveau système
d'information de la de la CNAM météore
qui devrait
qui devrait voilà embarquer un certain
nombre de
contrôles a priori et de système
autobloquant
sur le
oui c'est le plan de gouvernemental
suffira
là aussi il m'est difficile de dire ce
que nous constatons c'est que ça va dans
le bon sens il y a une prise de
conscience vraiment de la part de
l'ensemble des caisses d'assurance
maladie c'est certain de la part de
l'administration également et donc il y
a une vraie volonté de d'accélérer de
renforcer les moyens de lutte contre la
fraude le plan gouvernemental va
également dans le bon sens et nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir des différentes
mesures qui ont été qui ont été
annoncées est-ce que ça suffira le
problème de l'afrod mais je ne vous
apprends rien c'est évidemment que dès
que on met en place de nouveaux moyens
de lutte et de nouveaux moyens de
déceler les les d'identifier les
fraudeurs on a de nouveaux moyens de
contourner de contourner les dispositifs
et dès qu'on met en place de nouvelles
prestations il y a aussi des
contournements de donc voilà c'est un
c'est une politique difficile parce que
c'est une politique qui demande beaucoup
d'agilité beaucoup de réactivité pour
pouvoir s'adapter à aux Frau ur qui eux
s'adapte très très bien
voilà alors Corinne Imbert pour la
branche maladie ensuite René Paul Savary
pour la branche vieillesse Olivier nos
familles et philémonie pour la branche
autonomie merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente de la sixième
chambre je suis par là voilà
excusez-moi
permettez-moi de prendre peut-être un
petit moment pour vous parler de la
branche maladie sachant qu'elle porte en
2022 un déficit de 21 milliards d'euros
qui est supérieur à l'ensemble du
déficit de la Sécurité sociale tout
d'abord un point sur sur le pilotage de
hondables en commençant par une remarque
puisque sur landerne la coupe la cour
semble apporter le discours d'alerte que
le comité d'alerte peine à soutenir
lui-même peut-être vous entendre a-t-il
d'une part je constate que la course
souligne que la progression lambda met
actuellement prévue inférieure à la
dynamique de l'inflation et si la
procréation est anticipée plus haute que
l'inflation 2025 l'écart est réduit par
rapport à ce qui prévalait avant la
crise
la cour appelle dans son rapport à
conforté lambdame comme outil de
pilotage des dépenses et à infléchir les
dépenses de manière volontariste de
manière concrète et vous l'avez un petit
peu évoqué tout à l'heure dans vos dans
vos propos que préconisez-vous vous avez
parlé de mesure correctives quels
sont-elles et selon quelles calendrier
je m'interroge évidemment sur les
efforts que vous considérez urgent alors
que les hôpitaux sont en déficit qui
n'ont pas retrouvé leur niveau
d'activité de 2019 et que pour la
médecine de ville l'échec de la
convention médicale est notamment le
fait de revendications d'honoraires
au-delà des capacités financières de
l'assurance maladie
un mot sur la garantie de financement si
vous le permettez la Cour constate dans
son rapport le poids inédit et c'est
vrai de la garantie de financement des
établissements de santé qui
atteindraient en 2022,8 milliards
d'euros après avoir atteint 1,9
milliards d'euros en 2021 et 2,5
milliards d'euros en 2020 quel bilan
qualitatif la courte tire-t-elle se
dispositif avez-vous analysé son impact
sur la situation financière des
établissements et quelles conclusion la
courte tire-t-elle de cet exercice 2022
extrêmement fragile alors de manière
plus prospective
l'analyse de 2022 laisse anticipé une
situation extrêmement délicate en 2023
avec la sécurisation moduler à
l'activité qui est censée moins
compenser que ce que faisait la garantie
de financement elle en a pris le relais
et j'ai pu le constater la semaine
dernière en nouvelle Aquitaine lors d'un
déplacement je vous le disais les
établissements n'ont pas retrouvé le
niveau d'activité de 2019 avez-vous déjà
des éléments d'analyse sur l'exercice
2023 et sur l'écart de ressources qui
pourraient résulter de ce nouveau
dispositif qui est réduit il faut bien
se le dire la cour a-t-elle également
mené des travaux concernant l'évolution
du modèle de financement poste T2A
sur les investissements hospitaliers la
cour vous l'avez également dit constate
bien les besoins d'investissement des
établissements de santé le seigneur de
la santé nécessaire et davantage un
rattrapage c'est un effort mais c'est
surtout un rattrapage pour les
moderniser la modernisation qui
nécessite
cet effort est lui-même obérée par
l'inflation trop le moment où les
projets d'investissement ont été pensés
moins ils ont été évalués financièrement
au moment où ils sont prêts à être
exécutés on voit bien la différence en
montant du coup de l'investissement
la cour réalise-t-elle un suivi du Ségur
des investissements et quel regard
portez-vous sur l'évolution des
capacités d'autofinancement des
établissements et sur leur capacité
justement à soutenir aujourd'hui des
investissements indispensables à la
modernisation de notre système de santé
concernant les dépenses de soins de
ville vous évoquez dans le rapport la
nécessité de mieux piloter les dépenses
de soins de ville vous proposez
notamment de développer une rémunération
forfaitaire des professionnels de santé
pourriez-vous rappeler les principales
raisons pour lesquelles la part des
rémunérations forfaitaires
doit selon vous être renforcée et après
l'échec des négociations de la dernière
convention médicale les professionnels
de santé vous paraissent-elles prêtes à
accepter cette évolution
un mot sur les expérimentations
l'article 5 de l'articien 51 dont vous
avez rappelé qu'elles étaient trop
nombreuses et insuffisamment évaluées
pourriez-vous indiquer quelle priorité
devrait être selon vous fixer à ces
expérimentations et comment améliorer le
prix des projets
quels selon quels sont vos principales
propositions pour rendre plus efficace
ce dispositif et accélérer la
généralisation des expérimentations
concluantes qui le méritent évidemment
enfin un dernier mot sur la CADES
vous l'avez aussi évoqué
elle a été prolongée jusqu'en 2033
si j'ai bien lu votre rapport
il ne resterait à la cadèse que 8,8
milliards d'euros pour reprendre le
déficit
de 2023 qui est aujourd'hui
qui est aujourd'hui
je vous en prie pas de souci donc je
reviens sur la calesse il lui resterait
une capacité à absorber difficile à
hauteur de 8,8 milliards d'euros or le
déficit prévisionnel pour 2023 pardon
est estimé à 8,2 milliards d'euros
ça fait pas une grande marge de manœuvre
c'est moins de campus dire
je compte bien ça fait quoi 600 600
millions d'euros bref madame la
Présidente au delà de on va repousser
qu'en pensez-vous je vous remercie
pardonnez d'avoir été un petit peu
longue
madame la Présidente
sur
[Musique]
le pilotage de l'onde
alors
j'ai
de manière à lucive
évoquée tout à l'heure le fait que la
cour au mois de juillet va présenter
enfin le premier président va rendre
public des notes thématiques
structurelles pour contribuer à la
réflexion de l'exécutif sur les dépenses
publiques la revue des dépenses
publiques l'une de ces notes hématiques
réalisées par la sixième chambre sera
consacrée à
aux dépenses de soins de ville donc sans
déplorer totalement le sujet
je vais vous donner ici quelques
quelques réflexions
nous l'avons écrit plusieurs reprises
dans
plusieurs rapports l'enjeu est
évidemment
d'abord une meilleure organisation des
soins
au plan local notamment au plan
territorial entre l'hôpital public les
cliniques privées la médecine de ville
et avec des parcours de soins qui qui
soit effectif et non plus seulement un
objectif affiché mais qui soit effectif
pour soi DCP à ce qu'ils doivent
fonctionner correctement
des maisons de santé ou des centres de
santé enfin tout le dispositif que l'on
que l'on connaît mais qui tarde tout de
même à ce à se mettre en place en tout
cas dans un certain nombre de
territoires
les la réponse aux besoins
urgent j'en ai je l'évoquais aux besoins
urgent de soins je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure avec les Samus les SMUR et les
et les SAS mais là aussi il faut un bon
articulation avec la médecine de ville
d'une part avec les services
éventuellement hospitaliers de
réanimation avec des lits d'aval enfin
on voit bien que c'est toute la chaîne
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
repenser et en tout cas alors
c'est un effort de
continuer des pouvoirs publics on voit
bien avec une boîte à outils qui
s'enrichit années après année la
difficulté que nous voyons c'est que on
a une boîte à outils mais on n'a pas
nécessairement
l'articulation entre les différents
outils
concernant plus particulièrement
les grands postes de londam
soin de ville on a à peu près 40% des
dépenses qui sont le fait des
rémunérations des personnels médicaux et
paramédicaux on a ensuite un gros poste
avec les produits de santé donc
médicament à dispositif médicaux qui
représente un peu plus de 30% et ensuite
les indemnités journalières voilà voilà
pour les grands postes sur ces sur ces
postes là nous constatons
qu'il n'y a pas de mécanisme de
régulation infras annuel de régulation
financière infra annuelle et que
alors à l'exception du médicament je
vais en dire un mot et que les
les modalités de régulation plus
réanuelle que sont les négociations
conventionnelles ne sont pas utilisées
de manière aussi efficace qu'elle
pourrait l'être et en particulier à
certains noms de ces conventions
prévoient des dispositifs en cas de
nécessité que les pouvoirs publics n'ont
jamais actionné ou peu je pense par
exemple à la possibilité de décaler la
mise en oeuvre d'une convention
en particulier de la convention médicale
mais de ces valable pour toutes les
conventions au cas où le comité d'alerte
de la sécurité sociale
tire la sonnette d'alarme et voilà ça
n'a jamais été fait ça n'a jamais été
utilisé il y a d'autres dispositifs
comme ça au sein des conventions qui
sont des outils potentiellement
efficaces mais qui n'ont jamais été
utilisés
sur les mécanismes de régulation infra
annuels alors on a un mécanisme qui
fonctionne bien mais malheureusement qui
n'est pas suivi suffisamment dans le
temps c'est le mécanisme applicable aux
actes de biologie médicale une
régulation prévue qui a fait ses preuves
qui a été abandonnée pendant le covid et
voilà un petit peu de mal à remettre en
place et dont la cour pense qu'il
pourrait enfin
l'idée en tout cas d'une régulation prix
volumes pourrait sans doute inspirer
d'autres modes de régulation dans
d'autres secteurs que celui des
laboratoires de biologie médicale
la régulation de des produits de santé
des médicaments en tout cas
est relativement efficace avec le les
mesures de sauvegarde et les remises
donc ces deux outils à qui fonctionne
assez bien qui sont des cordes de rappel
alors je dis relativement parce que on a
quand même une augmentation assez rapide
du des médicaments en 2022 à + 4 % alors
que l'on dame prévoyait plus 2,7% et
et
l'avenir risque d'être également du
point de vue du
la tendance de coups des médicaments de
la dépense du médicament risque d'être
marquée par des dépenses en croissance
si la réaction industrialisation pardon
de la France en matière de médicaments
dont nous productions sur place des
médicaments comme c'est le volonté des
pouvoirs publics voit le jour
il y a peut-être là un risque de hausse
des dépenses de médicaments toujours
quand même un mot sur la régulation de
mon âme ce que nous avons dit c'est
qu'il y a un certain nombre d'outils qui
sont indispensables alors qui ne sont
pas seulement des outils de pilotage de
la dépense bien évidemment mais qui ont
un impact sur la dépense sur les
dépenses de santé c'est notamment toute
la mise en œuvre
numérique du numérique en santé on peut
penser à la prescription électronique on
peut penser au DMP au fameux dossiers
médical partagé qui devient maintenant
l'espace l'espace numérique en santé
voilà ça fait 20 ans que les pouvoirs
publics travaillent ça dit toujours pas
efficace aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train d'y consacrer d'ailleurs un
contrôle on voit que on a encore on est
en train d'engranger des retards
considérables en la matière par rapport
à nos autres grands pays d'Europe
même chose pour la donc pour la télé
santé or tous ces outils qui doivent
améliorer aussi l'efficacité la qualité
des soins éviter la hiatrogénie etc
sont des sources potentielles d'économie
indirecte mais sont des sources
potentielles d'économie le temps que
l'on met à les déployer est assez
problématique on peut parler aussi de la
révision des nomenclatures
qui sont qui sont obsolètes et dont on
peut attendre là aussi infinie des
économies on peut parler de la du
renforcement de la prévention enfin
voilà tous ces outils là on en parle la
cour on en parle les évoques rapport
après rapport vous allez les retrouver
concentrés dans notre notre sur les
soins de ville
à venir en juillet et bien sûr la lutte
contre la fraude mais j'en ai je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure pour ce qui
concerne le volet hospitalier
alors je vais peut-être laisser la
parole à Nicolas fourrier parce que non
seulement il ira porteurs général
durables mais vous avez la chance
d'avoir devant vous le rapporteur d'un
rapport qui sortira en septembre sur la
situation financière des hôpitaux
nous avons estimé indispensable
d'éclairer
les citoyens français sur la réalité de
la situation financière des hôpitaux et
notamment la sortie de la garantie de
financement et de mettre en parallèle
les la dette des hôpitaux et les
investissements réellement effectués et
de voir comment les les dotations ont
été ont été utilisées mais je vais
peut-être la laisser la parole à Nicolas
fourrier là-dessus
alors sur les trois points que vous avez
soulevé concernant la garantie de
financement tout d'abord la Cour a on va
dire une image nuancée de cette garantie
de financement nous pensons qu'en 2020
elle a été utile puisque avec la chute
très forte de l'activité hospitalière
notamment liée des déprogrammations qui
ont été des instructions qui ont été
envoyées par la DGOS pour ces
programmations pour laisser la place aux
personnes souffrances souffrant du covid
il a fallu maintenir un niveau de
ressources suffisant à l'ensemble des
établissements hospitaliers donc sur
2020 a été utile et encore en 2021 pour
ce qui concerne lier du fait pardon des
perturbations importantes du covid la
difficulté que l'on voit c'est que il y
a
je vais répéter le terme une certaine
difficulté
du ministère de la Santé à sortir de la
garantie de finance aujourd'hui le SMA
qui a été mis en place pour pro 2023
c'est une garantie de financement à 70%
on reste bien dans une logique qui est
qui est la même or tous les entretiens
que nous avons eu dans les dans les
différentes hôpitaux avec les
différentes fédérations nous ont
confirmé qu'il y a un attachement qui
reste extrêmement fort à la T2A
attachement que la Cour des comptes
partage il y a également un rapport qui
doit sortir sur le sujet de la T2A donc
la T2A elle a ses défauts elle peut être
critiquée elle est notamment beaucoup
trop complexe
l'organisation GS alors GHS et vraiment
beaucoup trop compliqué et le lien entre
les coûts et les tarifs et pourraient
être plus précis qu'il ne l'est dans la
tarification actuelle donc elle a certes
ses défauts mais elle présente des
avantages extrêmement importants qui est
comme son nom l'indique de lier la
rémunération des établissements à leur
activité or un établissement sa vie il y
a des services qui ferment il y a des
établissements qui fusionnent et les
systèmes qui existaient antérieurement
de la dotation globale et qui est revenu
en fait à travers la garantie de
financement ne permet pas de prendre en
compte cette vie de l'hôpital d'où
nous pensons que dans les réformes qui
sont à venir il est important de garder
une dimension prépondérante à la à la
tarification à l'activité pour autant la
Cour des comptes n'est pas partie
prenante de cette réforme de par de par
son statut donc de participe pas aux
réflexions qui sont en cours au sein des
administrations et du gouvernement
concernant le Ségur de de
l'investissement
alors nous suivons le seigneur de
l'investissement et ce sera une des
parties très importante du rapport que
nous allons produire sur la situation
financière des hôpitaux
en septembre
probablement il y a eu trop de projets
qui ont été validés par rapport au
montant de l'enveloppe qui représente
pourtant 9 milliards d'euros si on
additionne les deux les deux sous
enveloppes qui ont été alloués à louer
par l'État pour les Ségur de
l'investissement mais le nombre de
projets est trop a été trop important et
avec l'augmentation de l'inflation des
coûts de la construction on constate que
les taux d'aide par projet sont sans
doute trop bas au regard des capacités
financières des établissements donc il
va falloir trouver une solution il
appartient pas la cour de dire qu'elle
est cette solution à enveloppe constante
la solution serait de d'abandonner un
certain nombre de projets de
redimensionner d'autres de reprogrammer
donc il y a un travail important à
réaliser mais une vraie difficulté
qu'on met en relation les enveloppes qui
ont été prévues pour le Ségur de la
santé et le montant du programme
d'investissement qui a été réalisé par
les établissements les commissions
médicales d'établissement et qui ont été
à ce jour mais pas complètement validé
par les ARS puisque la validation
définitive des projets d'investissement
par les ARS se fait en trois phases et
on est au passage actuellement de la
deuxième phase qui est la phase
véritablement décisionnelle donc c'est
dans les mois qui viennent que les
décisions vont venir donc voilà sur ce
sur ces sujets hospitaliers
j'ajoute là aussi que la Cour va publier
en septembre
donc un rapport sur la même en juillet
en réalité un rapport sur la T2A
donc voilà ce sera publié sur le site de
la cour à ce stade il y aura pas de
communication particulière en revanche
en septembre comme nous avons donc trois
rapports qui concernent l'hôpital qui
sont trois rapports importants l'un sur
la T2A qui va sortir en juillet l'autre
sur la situation financière des hôpitaux
et le troisième sur la concurrence et la
complémentarité entre les établissements
de santé publique et les établissements
de santé privés nous font sans doute un
voilà une communication particulière en
septembre pour la sortie de au moins de
ces de ces deux rapports la T2A sortants
je vous l'ai dit en juillet
vous avez également posé une question
sur le mode de rémunération des des
médecins libéraux
nous nous appelons effectivement à
augmenter la part forfaitaire de l'arrêt
numération
la part forfaitaire liée notamment à des
obligations de services publics
aujourd'hui le paiement à l'acte
représente plus de 80% de la
rémunération des médecins libéraux et
avec un certain nombre d'effets pervers
d'une part l'effet inflationniste qui a
été démontré par par beaucoup
l'insuffisance de prévention puisque
rien n'est fait dans le système actuel à
part la rémunération obligation de
service public pour inciter à des
actions de prévention de la part des
libéraux et peut-être aussi une
diminution de la durée des consultations
donc on voit qu'il y a aussi un certain
nombre de d'effets pervers qui peuvent
qui peuvent être engendrés dans cette
une rémunération qui serait 100% une
rémunération à l'acte et donc ce que
nous constatons c'est que l'objectif
d'accroître la part de rémunération
forfaitaire n'a pas été atteint cet
objectif existait il n'a pas été atteint
par la Convention il existe enfin il
était fixé dans la convention médicale
de 2016 et il n'a pas été atteint et
nous pensons que cette forfaitisation
est souhaitable elle peut prendre
plusieurs fois
par épisode de soins par professionnel
par patient
en tout état de cause une rémunération
de la prise en charge enfin une
forêtisation accrue la rémunération de
la prise en charge des patients atteints
de pathologies chroniques nous sommes
une priorité ce qui m'amène peut-être à
aux expérimentations articles 51 puisque
parmi ces expérimentations
trois nous paraissent particulièrement
structurante
le paiement justement à l'épisode de
soins
et pour pour trois types d'interventions
chirurgicales mais mais cette
expérimentation là nous semble
prometteuse le paiement en équipe d'un
ensemble de professionnels de santé et
puis l'intéressement de groupements de
professionnels à la performance de la
qualité des soins de la satisfaction des
patients et de la maîtrise des dépenses
donc ce sont trois expérimentations dont
nous suivrons les résultats avec
attention elles seront terminées dans un
an à peu près à la mi-2024 et
elle si et si elles sont aussi
prometteuses que enfin si les résultats
sont au rendez-vous nous espérons et
nous appellerons nos vœux le fait
qu'elle soit généralisée dans les
meilleurs délais
sur la sur la cadette
oui vous avez
très bien résumé la
problématique des 8 milliards
voilà et pour un potentiel de unilar 8
et donc la nécessité
selon la Cour de prolonger dans les
meilleurs délais la durée de vie de la
cadèse pour lui permettre de faire face
à la reprise de ces déficits
un Street à perpétuité
après cette remarque je vais laisser la
parole à René Paul Savary
merci de remarques madame présidente
votre analyse sur la rémunération des
médecins généralistes
me laissent dubitative
contenu du contexte où on en manque
qu'il faut inciter nos jeunes je suis
pas sûr que ce soit à travers ce type de
rémunération qu'on les incite
deuxièmement vous apprenons un mot qui
m'a plu en ce qui concerne la clause de
sauvegarde en disant que cette doit être
une corde de rappel quand la gloses de
sauvegarde va atteindre 2023 plus d'un
milliard d'euros par rapport aux
prévisions c'est plus une corde de
rappel c'est une taxation sur les
médicaments donc faut rester vigilant
par rapport à ça et garder le principe
justement de la clause de sauvegarde
pour la maîtrise des médicaments sans
que ça devienne prohibitif parce que
sinon on va décourager véritablement un
certain nombre de laboratoires à
investir en France à nous produire des
médicaments ils vont aller ailleurs et
on va constater plus de pénurie je ferme
la parenthèse je reviens à ceux qui me
regarde davantage à savoir la branche
vieillesse où vous dites que
la réforme ne comble pas le le le
déficit et effectivement compte tenu des
mesures d'accompagnement que l'on a pris
que l'on a voté au Parlement ce qui
concerne les carrières longues en ce qui
concerne la rémunération des petites
retraites à travers le micro ou d'autres
dispositifs importants notamment la
revalorisation des pensions des femmes à
travers justement une mesure importante
avec quand vous avez des trimestres
supplémentaires une retraite majorée
quand vous avez parallèlement le nombre
d'années ce qui me fait dire que la
réforme contribue à limiter la
différence de traitement entre ceux qui
concerne les retraites des femmes et des
hommes contrairement à ce que vous avez
affirmé madame c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voulais souligner ce ce
dispositif et d'autre part je pense
qu'il faut voir et ce que ne vous ne
voyez pas effectivement à travers cette
analyse
l'ensemble du système de retraite avec
les retraites complémentaires voilà
parce que les retraites complémentaires
par rapport à une logement de la durée
et un décalage de l'art de l'âge vont
être elles davantage bénéficiaires
notamment la gîte Arrco qui représente
quand même la majorité de nos personnes
retraitées et en conséquence ce qu'il
faut voir peut-être dans l'analyse en
tout cas être prudent dans les dans les
commentaires c'est de voir davantage le
système sur le plan de ça globalité
voilà les remarques que je souhaitais
faire qui ne sont pas des questions mais
les remarques vous l'avez là aussi
remarqué
très bien on va prendre Olivier nous sur
la planche famille on va prendre les
deux branches
non merci madame la Présidente d'abord
une remarque de
portée générale en vous remerciant de la
qualité du rapport comme ça a été dit
par la rapporteur général pour notre
apporteur général mais aussi vos propos
qui nous éclairent et quand même la
présidente a une expression imagée mais
assez juste la Cadès à perpétuité oui
sauf que ça c'est très juste et ça
quelque chose d'inquiétant si les
générations qui nous suivent regardent
et peuvent ma manifester quelques
inquiétudes parce que transférer sur les
générations à venir nos dépenses
sociales c'est quand même pas gage de de
responsabilité on finit par l'oublier
transférer et investir pour l'avenir
transférer une dette d'investissement
sur l'avenir ses responsables mais des
dépenses sociales et des dépenses
courantes tout de même ça ça pose
question il m'a semblé nécessaire de le
dire et donc on voit bien notre niveau
de dépense on a un niveau de dépense
élevé sur nos comptes sociaux on a une
dégradation des comptes et pourtant on a
toujours tout le temps chers collègues
une dialectique sur l'infus suffisance
des moyens en permanence c'est encore on
avait un niveau de dépenses élevé une
dette importante des comptes sociaux
dégradés mais qu'au moins il y avait une
satisfaction ben non on a une
dialectique sur l'insuffisance des
moyens et donc on voit bien que lors de
la remise à plat au lendemain du du quoi
qu'il en coûte et d'une grande loi santé
et même de nos comptes sociaux va sonner
parce qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça
il y a quelque chose là il y a une
équation impossible alors sur la branche
famille
moi je je trouve que le refus de
certification et et sonner comme une
évidence c'est de votre responsabilité
bien sûr mais enfin quand même on reste
sans voix 5 milliards d'indus et
rappelle et je vous écoute face à cette
réalité la CAF où il y a moins de
contrôle j'ai entendu et finalement pas
de plan de redressement à court voir un
moyen terme excusez du peu on reste sans
voix et je pense que il serait bon quand
même que les pouvoirs publics soient
plus vigoureux sur cette question et que
le gouvernement s'adresse un peu plus
directement à la cave parce que c'est
pas acceptable sur des montants comme ça
alors maintenant sur les questions plus
techniques qu'il y avait été longtemps
débattu sur les indemnités journalières
versées après la naissance de l'enfant
le Sénat s'y était opposé vous en
souvenez dans notre rapport venant votre
rapport vous pointez la nature
conventionnelle d'une distinction entre
plonger prénatal et postnatale et vous
recommandez dès lors de clarifier le
financement de congé maternité en le
confiant en totalité à la branche
famille nous pouvons vous suivre sur ce
point mais par contre on a des
difficultés avec la conclusion que vous
en tirez vous reconnaissez-vous même
quand qu'une meilleure connaissance des
dépenses liées au congés maternité sur
un instrument de prévention et de suivi
de la santé périnatale vous préconisez à
cette occasion d'améliorer les
dispositifs de suivi de la santé des
femmes dès lors pour quelle raison
estimez-vous que la Caisse nationale des
allocations familiales a davantage
vocation à financer le congé maternité
que l'Assurance Maladie pour sur cette
question puisque ça a été longuement
débattu lors du précédent PLFSS deuxième
question vous dressez également un bilan
peut satisfaisant de la gestion des
congés maternités paternité le Sénat
supprimé lors de l'examen du dernier PEL
FSS le versement obligatoire des IJ par
les employeurs pour le compte des
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie
cette disposition n'avait pas
d'incidence sur les contes de la
activités sociales ce que d'ailleurs le
Conseil constitutionnel a confirmer et
transférer une charge de trésorerie
excessive aux employeurs vous nous
confirmez que ces derniers doivent
attendre 42 jours plus de 42 jours
d'ailleurs 42,6 jours en moyenne pour
obtenir le remboursement donc vous
qualifiez de prometteuse la subrogation
obligatoire vous n'en faites toutefois
pas une recommandation est-ce que vous
estimez comme nous l'avons fait que la
gestion par les CPAM des congés
maternités paternité ne permet pas cette
réforme et que la génération du
transfert d'information par les
employeurs via la déclaration de social
nominative ne serait-elle pas suffisante
à éviter les ruptures de ressources pour
les mères ce qui est évidemment le cœur
du sujet je vous remercie
oui merci alors même si ça n'était
qu'une remarque je vais abonder dans ce
que disait René Paul Savary en effet
les l'impact de la réforme des retraites
est positif pour sur l'agir Carco et et
pour l'État aussi on a 3 + 3,7 milliards
d'euros pour l'agircargo plus un
milliard pour l'État nous n'avons pas
dit le contraire nous nous sommes
concentrés nous sur le régime général
puisque telene notre mission notamment
dans la certification des comptes mais
mais nous partageons bien sûr ce constat
pour ce qui est de donc de la branche
famille
alors sur la cohérence des du
financement des congés maternités
paternité nous n'avons pas attendu
pardon 2023 déjà en 2022 nous
recommandons que les congés paternité et
les congés maternités soient gérés par
la même branche qui n'est pas le cas
puisqu'en 2022 les congés paternités
étaient supportés par la branche famille
et les congés paternité
dans son intégralité dans leur
intégralité pardon par la branche
maladie donc il y a déjà eu un effort de
regroupement mais ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que le regroupement enfin elle est
fort de cohérence a eu jusqu'au bout
alors
nous nous appelons enfin on se prononce
pas nécessairement sur la branche
famille ou la branche ou la branche
maladie il se trouve que la branche la
branche famille s'agissant de de
prestations qui sont déjà quasiment
totalité un branche famille mériterait
d'être finalement regroupé dans la
branche famille et seuls les congés
pathologiques alors liés à la maternité
resterait bien sûr à la à la branche
maladie mais c'est vraiment un message
de cohérence des financements et de
cohérence du pilotage
sur les la gestion et le
desigils liés à la maternité à la
paternité et à la question de la
subrogation
comme vous l'avez souligné les
indemnités journalières enfin la charge
de trésorerie relative à la subrogation
des indemnités journalières maternité et
paternité peut représenter une charge
importante notamment pour les toutes
petites entreprises ça nous en sommes
tout à fait conscient mais d'un autre
côté le retard de versement de ces
indemnités pèse sur les foyers et
notamment les foyers les plus modestes
qui sont privés de ce droit puisque les
délais sont ce que vous avez rappelés en
moyenne en moyenne de 42 jours et c'est
pour éviter de telles ruptures de
ressources pour les ménages les plus
fragiles qui sont encore trop fréquentes
que la Cour
estime prometteuse la subrogation
obligatoire
nous nous rappelons que le caractère
obligatoire la subrogation permettrait
de répondre
à la pratique irrégulière qui consiste
pour certains employeurs à subordonné le
versement des indemnités dues à leurs
employés au fait que même était reçu de
la de la sécurité sociale le
remboursement et donc cette pratique est
totalement illégale et c'est aussi pour
répondre à ses pratiques donc
irrégulières que nous faisons une
recommandation de subrogation
obligatoire
alors on en a pas fait une
recommandation à proprement parler parce
que
[Musique]
lors de la délibéré
sur ce sur ce rapport la mesure avec
alors été proposée par le gouvernement
dans le PLFSS bon c'est ce qu'il en est
à devenu mais sinon nous aurions fait la
recommandation en bonne et due forme
[Musique]
voilà et alors en effet on attend
beaucoup de la de la DSN qui devrait
normalement améliorer au moins les temps
de transmission des informations et la
qualité de ces de ces informations
financières nécessaires aux calculs des
indemnités
pour la branche autonomie
principale qui concerne le sol de la
branche puisque
le seul dans 2022 a finalement été
beaucoup plus favorable qu'annoncée il y
a 6 mois avec notamment un excédent
d'environ 5 milliards d'euros 0,5
milliards d'euros et alors que
normalement les prévisions étaient
plutôt un léger déficit de 200 millions
d'euros c'était clair et dû à la fois
des recettes qui ont été plus
importantes et elles progression des
dépenses plus modérée attendue alors
comment expliquez-vous le moindre niveau
des dépenses entre les prévisions qui
étaient retenues dans LFSS pour 2023 et
en définitif est-ce que l'impact des
relations salariales qui étaient quand
même le la dépense nouvelle relativement
importante a été finalement minimisée à
travers la gestion de la branche et dans
quelle mesure la dynamique de recette
est liée à l'inflation et dans ce
contexte faut-il s'inquiéter que les
dépenses n'est pas été plus élevées
étant donné les besoins de la branche
qui sont importants notamment au regard
de la gestion du vieillissement
dites-nous vous savez ces domicile et
bien entendu des besoins en matière du
handicap
je vous laisse répondre sur cette
question et ensuite on va passer aux
questions des commissaires d'accord
alors sur le effectivement la branche
autonomie a des résultats meilleurs que
attendus alors sur l'augmentation des
recettes on la constate évidemment pour
l'ensemble des branches de la sécurité
sociale elle élit notamment à
l'inflation il faut bien avoir en tête
que 1% d'inflation ça génère 1% pardon
de l'inflation un impact sur la masse
salariale qui augmente et 1%
d'augmentation de la masse salariale
c'est 2,2 milliards d'euros de recettes
en plus pour la sécurité sociale donc la
branche autonomie n'échappe pas à la
règle et a effectivement une dynamique
de de recettes plus importantes que
prévu alors les dépenses les dépenses un
peu moins élevées que que prévu mais
très très peu en réalité en ligne donc
l'écart s'explique essentiellement par
cette dynamique des recettes liée à
l'augmentation de de
l'assiette de des cotisations
très bien alors Cathy a pour ce poli
victoire jasmin Daniel Chassagne
Jean-Marie vanenberg à la mylon merci
bien Madame la président tous les
commissaires donc je vais essayer d'être
rapide alors le rapport de la Cour des
comptes d'enfer focus sur la situation
de la CNR Racl qui est de plus en plus
préoccupante il faut se le dire ce
régime spécial vous l'avez dit que vous
les risques retraités invalidité des
agents de la fonction publique
territoriale et hospitalière et il
rencontre un déficit devenu finalement
structurel
qui est appelé à s'aggraver 6,6
milliards d'euros si j'ai bien compris
en 2030
la loi de fonctionnement de la sécurité
sociale 2023 autorisé un emprunt de
7,5 milliards d'euros pour assurer la
pérennité des paiements et des
prestations
avec évidemment des taux d'intérêt qui
remontent cette solution nous le savons
tous et toutes et coûteuse donc quelles
préconisations cette fête vous pour
trouver une solution financière et
garantir les comptes finalement de la
CNRACL une deuxième question vous
préconisez de faire des économies en
maîtrisant davantage les dépenses de
médicaments mais il me semble que vous
n'avez rien dit sur l'usage de la
pertinence des 6 milliards d'euros du
crédit un peu recherche
avez-vous proposé au gouvernement
d'augmenter le reste à charge des
ménages en doublant la franchise sur les
médicaments c'est ma deuxième question
et puis la troisième sur les retraites
homme-femmes les quarts des pensions
hommes femmes vous l'avez dit et le
rapport des comptes préconise donc de
faire des économies sur les pensions de
réversion
quelle vision pour moi de l'égalité
enfin donc pouvez-vous me confirmer cela
et puis ne pensez-vous pas que les
Galactiques salariales peut-être une
source de revenus supplémentaires qu'il
faut essayer de creuser et voilà
j'arrête parce que j'ai encore plein de
questions mais je veux laisser la place
à mes collègues
merci madame la Présidente alors j'ai
deux questions la première concerne les
plus de 22% des appels au SAMU alors
est-ce que vous avez des éléments plus
fins pour comprendre pourquoi est-ce le
manque de médecin et ma deuxième
question les travailleurs indépendants
et les conjoints et leur conjoint les
conjoints et les agriculteurs sont
pénalisés par le non en cours au doigt
et aux soins alors est-ce que vous avez
des éléments également permettant de
mieux comprendre les raisons j'envoie
merci Daniel Chassin merci madame la
Présidente merci madame la Présidente la
Cour des comptes donc moi j'aurais deux
questions
concernant le SAMU donc vous avez dit
une augmentation de 62% depuis 2014 mais
ça c'est quand même dû effectivement
un médecin régulateur du SAS qui arrive
en plus du médecin régulateur du SAMU
est-ce que vous pensez que
quand même cette façon de mettre en
place
pour
régler les soins non programmés avec les
médecins libéraux et les maisons de
santé des CPS n'est pas quand même
pertinent et enfin au niveau de lambdame
est-ce que dans vos déficits prévus vous
avez anticipé ce qui avait dit le
président de la République c'est-à-dire
d'augmenter le nombre d'emplois pour les
personnes dépendantes et qui sont très
attendus dans les EHPAD et aussi bien
sûr je voudrais dire que les les projets
concernant les hôpitaux avec la avec
l'inflation on pris au moins 30%
de de coûte en plus et enfin dernière
question
concernant la vieillesse donc on n'est
pas le Savary a indiqué que le Sénat
avait apporté si vous voulez
des clauses pour les femmes les
carrières longues etc les petites
retraites et vous nous avez indiqué un
déficit dans les années 2030 malgré le
vote de la de la réforme quel est le
quel sera le déficit dans à votre avis
dans les années 2030 2040 merci
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la présidente de la cour des contes pour
vos informations j'ai deux questions à
vous poser le gouvernement t'ont lancé
le grand chantier du dispositif de
solidarité à la source qui doit
permettre de lutter contre le non-retour
le non recours tout en limitant les
risques de fraude est-ce que vous avez
une estimation soit des économies soit
des dépenses supplémentaires qui peuvent
être envisagées
dans ce cas là et la deuxième question
vous en avez parlé un peu tout à l'heure
et vous l'avez souligné dans le rapport
de la Cour des comptes
vous rappelez que certains textes
d'application reste à publier et que
les différents ministères ont pas mal de
retard dans la publication des décrets
d'application alors est-ce que vous avez
des explications des ministères sur le
pourquoi est-ce que vous préconisez des
solutions vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
des systèmes informatiques qui mettaient
plus de parfois jusqu'à 20 ans être mis
en place voilà qu'est-ce que vous
proposez comme solution merci Jean-Marie
vannerenberg
la présidente merci Madame j'ai une
question
peut-être un peu plus
multiples sur la fraude vous avez noté
effectivement que la fraude aux
cotisations
bien qu'un parfaite dans son estimation
puisque de la CNAM nous n'avons que des
données partielles 29% seulement du
total des prestations ont été
effectivement estimées
ce qui est trop peu et nous l'avons
signalé au directeur de la CNAM il y a
très peu de temps celui-ci a validé les
chiffres que
extrapoler de en gros 7 à 8 milliards
sur
le total des prestations ce que vous et
5 environ 5 milliards sur ce qui
concerne peut-être la CNAM 4 à 5
milliards
est-ce que vous les confirmez
compte tenu effectivement des contrôles
que vous avez effectués
on est étonné du retard de la CNAM on
sait qu'ils ont été les dernières
semaines effectivement à faire des
estimations mais ils prennent encore du
retard dans la conduite de ces
opérations
et donc il y a certainement un problème
de méthode
vous soulignez d'ailleurs
à juste titre que certains certaines
caisses ont engagé effectivement des
améliorations on évoquait la CAF même si
on peut s'étonner que les redressements
soient pas à la hauteur effectivement
des estimations qui ont été effectuées
on est toujours autour de 3 milliards de
fraudes
et on voit pas effectivement
d'évaluation enfin de d'amélioration
dans le retour je pense qu'il y a un
problème de méthode peut-être aussi un
problème de moyens vous soulignez
notamment qui manque de contrôleurs
nous l'avons dit et répéter ici Matt et
mannequin je crois que de multiplier des
contrôleurs à l'évidence sera un effet
bénéfique pour tout le monde c'est pas
de Spa des dépenses je dirais
supplémentaire sont des dépenses
d'investissement on peut considérer de
la sorte compte tenu effectivement des
recettes qu'il y a vous n'évoquez pas du
tout les fraudes
dans un précédent rapport vous l'évoquez
vous parliez de 6 à 8 milliards est-ce
que vous les confirmez encore
aujourd'hui parce que vous voyez que si
on additionne les deux fraude
prestations fraude cotisation on arrive
à un chiffre compris en entre 13 et 16
milliards c'est énorme
c'est loin des fantasmes à 40 ou 50
milliards que certains ont évoqué mais
je crois que quand on cherche
aujourd'hui de l'argent et des économies
à faire
j'ai entendu monsieur le ministre dire
que c'est pas dans les fraudes qu'on
allait trouver si je suis au regret de
dire ministre qu'il y a là effectivement
une quinzaine de milliards supérieure ou
10 milliards qu'ils recherchent
qui sont effectivement à activer en tous
les cas il faut vraiment renforcer
considérablement et je crois que
l'action de la Cour des comptes dans ce
sens peut que renforcer celle du
département terre et du Sénat en
particulier je terminerai en disant que
vous soulignez les progrès dans la
sécurisation des inscriptions des
personnes étrangères à la sécurité
sociale
nous nous y étions penchés et nous
avions fait un certain nombre de
recommandations que vous aviez validé je
m'en remets effectivement à votre
rapport pour dire bon ça avance dans le
bon sens quoi dans ce mais on était loin
quand même des estimations fantaisistes
qui avaient été annoncé de 14 milliards
on était à 140 millions dans notre
rapport merci beaucoup Alain Milan pour
terminer
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais revenir sur ce que sur la
question de Corinne Imbert concernant la
T2A et la réponse faite par Monsieur
fourrier
si si
mes lectures sont bonnes la tête de ça
l'intervient qu'à hauteur de 60% dans
les budgets des hôpitaux les migres les
migasques les mairies etc interviennent
pour le reste dans les budgets des
hôpitaux et beaucoup actuellement
condamnent la T2A alors que la T2A a
sauvé les hôpitaux c'est une évidence de
budget global enterrant ceci et
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que certains
systèmes qui sont ne sont pas encore
sous T2A demande à arriver en T2A et en
particulier la psychiatrie et le système
privé alors vous avez dit monsieur que
il y a une enquête Madame et Monsieur
pardon qui a une enquête de la cour sur
le sujet un rapport qui sera commis
bientôt j'ai hâte de pouvoir le dire de
la même façon d'ailleurs qu'un rapport
de ligace doit être mis en place dans
les jours qui viennent j'ai rendez-vous
avec la présidente de ce de cette
commission le 12 juillet prochain parce
que je voulais dire vous avez dit que la
T2A était complexe
est-ce que c'est la T2A qui est complexe
ou est-ce que c'est son utilisation qui
a complexifié la T2A parce que si on
regarde bien l'évolution des tarifs aux
États-Unis en 40 ans de T2A et les
évolutions des tarifs en France en 20
ans de T2A il y a deux fois plus de
tarifs en France qu'aux États-Unis donc
c'est plutôt l'utilisation d'un T2A qui
a complexifié celle-ci parfois vous
pouvez répondre sur le sujet ma question
c'est la suivante elle ne concerne pas
la T2R elle concerne les investissements
immobiliers est-il normal qu'un
organisme qui n'est pas propriétaire de
l'immobilier autofinance empreinte et
rembourse les emprunts pour le
propriétaire qui lui ne fait rien
d'autre que de que d'abonder un petit
peu vous l'avez dit d'une manière assez
restreinte d'ailleurs le financement de
ses investissements immobiliers
j'entends bien dire les bâtiments l'État
est propriétaire des bâtiments c'est pas
l'assurance maladie qui ont des
propriétaires est-il normal que
l'assurance maladie rembourse les
emprunts pour pour ces bâtiments
beaucoup de questions
sur la scène la question sur la
scnr-a.cl nous pouvons que confirmer
effectivement ce qui est écrit dans le
rapport c'est à dire ce que nous
anticipons à toutes choses égales par
ailleurs si aucun des aucun des
paramètres du régime échangé un déficit
de 6,6 milliards d'euros à l'horizon
les paramètres on les connaît le
l'augmentation du taux de cotisation
patronale récemment décidé sera sera
insuffisante donc à couvrir ces déficits
après ça n'est pas à la cour de se
prononcer sur la manière quel levier
utiliser notamment entre le montant de
la pension ou
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales ou salariales
c'est au pouvoir public de décider
quelle utilisation ils font de ces
leviers
sur
oui juste une précisé quand même sur
le la multiplication par deux de la
l'annonce de l'augmentation de la
franchise à la charge des assurés
sociaux sur les médicaments par le
gouvernement tout à fait récemment ça
n'est pas une idée qui a été soufflée
par la Cour des comptes si c'était le
sens de la question
sur les pensions et notamment les
pensions de réversion alors je ne
voudrais pas qu'on puisse croire que la
Cour des comptes et la présidente de la
sixième chambre particulière suggère de
faire des économies sur les pensions de
réversion ça n'est pas du tout notre
propos
nous ne préconisons pas de faire
d'économies dans ce dans ce domaine
nous préconisons de mieux
au contraire de de continuer à combler
par des mécanismes de solidarité ou de
réversion l'écart de pension que nous
constatons entre les femmes et les
hommes comme vous l'avez dit très
justement
c'est aussi en s'attaquant aux problèmes
des salaires donc en amont que on
résoudra dans le temps
l'écart entre le problème de l'écart
entre les salaires des femmes et les
salaires des hommes bien évidemment et
c'est un point que nous mentionnons dans
le rapport
sur les
les Samus la hausse des appels est-elle
liée au manque de médecin
alors je voudrais juste rappeler une
chose c'est que le depuis 5-6 ans on
constate une augmentation des personnels
de santé médicaux et des médecins sauf
pour les médecins généralistes donc
c'est la seule catégorie dont les
effectifs baissent mais pour le reste on
constate une augmentation
et j'aurais tendance à répondre on n'a
pas
d'études précises là-dessus mais que
c'est
aussi
la comment dire
l'attitude le comportement des patients
et assurer sociaux que nous sommes tous
et qui ont tendance à appeler le SAMU et
aller directement aux urgences ou aller
aux urgences via le SAMU
[Musique]
voilà c'est pour ça que même si l'état
de santé en réalité ne relève pas de de
SAMU encore moins d'un semure je vous
rappelle que les transports
médicalisés
d'urgence enfin qui dont l'état justifié
par l'état de santé du patient ne
représente que 5% du total des appels
s'amus donc sur 100 appels seul 5 se
traduisent effectivement par un
transport médicalisé d'urgence vers
l'hôpital le plus proche
alors l'objectif du ça c'est bien
évidemment
d'essayer de traiter en amont tous ces
appels qui se déversent vers le SAMU et
que ne nécessite pas
un transport médicalisé et qui ne relève
pas d'une urgence et de pouvoir les
réorienter vers la médecine de ville
dans les 48 heures ce qui est
aujourd'hui un peu une gageure dans
certains territoires beaucoup moins dans
d'autres mais les sons au moins au
dispositif le temps de se mettre en
place et nous serons très attentifs à la
Cour des comptes à aux résultats de ces
de ces services d'accès aux soins
sur
oui sur les
fraudes alors
[Musique]
je n'arrive même plus à me relire
alors c'était sur les retraites c'était
sur les retraites pardon et sur les
l'appréciation que nous portions sur
la situation voilà les conjoints des
agriculteurs en matière de retraite
alors c'est un sujet que nous n'avons
pas creusé particulièrement
on constate en tout cas
sur les dans d'autres dans d'autres sur
d'autres modes de prestation on constate
des inégalités entre les salariés et les
non salariés sur la question des
retraites et des conjoints de retraite
d'agriculteurs et des conjoints
d'agriculteurs en particulier je pense
qu'on doit faire les mêmes constats mais
c'est un sujet que nous n'avons pas
creusé mais ça peut nous aider ça nous
donner une idée de de contrôle à venir
sur
[Musique]
déficit 2030 alors 2040 nous n'avons pas
le chiffre et 2030 nous l'avons et nous
l'avons donné dans le rapport toutes
choses égales par ailleurs c'est-à-dire
à un modèle inchangé voilà où nous
amènerait la situation actuelle et
compte tenu aussi des des
hypothèses voilà des hypothèses
gouvernementales
que par ailleurs nous dont nous
soulignons l'optimisme que s'agisse de
taux de croissance de taux d'inflation
on a des hypothèses qui sont que nous
avons jugé
dont nous avons jugé qu'elle n'était pas
hors d'attente mais qu'elles étaient
optimistes
donc voilà pour l'instant nous nous
entenons à ces assez considérations et
ce chiffrage puisque nous ne refaisons
pas nous les modèles et les qui sont qui
sont proposés soit par le corps en
matière de retraite soit par le
gouvernement sur d'autres sujets
et nous nous constatons
que les hypothèses encore une fois sont
assez éloignés quand on les prend une
par une
toujours optimiste par rapport aux
consensus soit des des de l'OCDE de la
Commission européenne du FMI donc
systématiquement nos prévisions sont un
peu plus sur chaque critère un peu plus
optimiste et donc la conjonction de
l'ensemble de ces hypothèses
chacune optimistes
nous conduit à penser que voilà il faut
il faut être vigilant et que et que les
déficits le déficit 2030 pourrait être
supérieur si les choses se passaient
moins bien que escompté dans les
hypothèses que j'ai citées
sur la solidarité à la source
est-ce que ça conduit à des économies ou
à des dépenses supplémentaires nous
espérons ça conduira à des économies en
tout cas ça conduira et c'est un
objectif à
plus grande pertinence de
l'allocation de de prestations
ça permettra aussi donc on parlait des
20% de rappel tout à l'heure voilà
d'éviter à un certain nombre de ménages
qui en ont des droits et qui peut être
l'ignore éviter de passer au travers de
dispositifs auxquels ils ont droit mais
ce surcroît entre guillemets de dépenses
occasionnée par les personnes qui
recevraient des prestations quelles
elles ont droit et auxquelles elles
n'ont pas fait appel jusqu'à présent
serait semble-t-il largement compensés
par le fait que on gagnerait nettement
en gestion
et en temps de gestion sur les textes
d'applications qui sont en retard oui
nous le constatons nous le regrettons
nous n'avons pas d'explications et nous
espérons que notre message sur ce sujet
notamment au sénateur et sénatrice que
vous êtes comme nous l'avons fait passer
aussi à l'Assemblée nationale aura
peut-être des effets
accélérateurs dans la prise des décrets
que nous attendons sur la question de la
fraude alors effectivement on confirme
ce chiffre de 6 à 8 milliards
nous confirmons aussi le chiffre que
nous avions donné sur la fraude au
cotisations d'environ 8 milliards
d'euros également donc le chiffre que
vous avez avancé d'un total compris
entre 12 et 16 milliards d'euros et
confirmé à ce stade sachant que nous
n'avons pas réinstruit la question de la
fraude aux cotisations on y reviendra
mais depuis le dernier rapport qu'il y
ait un problème de méthode
c'est certain même si nous soulignons
les progrès qui ont été faits et
notamment les caisses dotent d'outils
informatiques permettant de
d'identifier mieux les profils a priori
des fraudeurs de manière à aller porter
leur contrôle essentiellement sur ses
profils comme le data mining ou d'autres
d'autres
choses de ce genre un problème de moyens
je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure des moyens
humains et des moyens informatiques et
oui la photo
[Musique]
et le ciblage a priori des contrôles qui
devrait permettre là aussi tout le tout
toute la les moyens qui sont consacrés à
la fraude
aujourd'hui
pourraient être
avec la prise en compte dans les
systèmes d'information d'un certain
nombre d'éléments bloquants ou
d'éléments permettant de repérer mieux
les fraudeurs en amont on économise là
aussi des moyens qui peuvent être
redéployés sur le contrôle aposteriori
qui reste absolument indispensable qu'il
s'agisse de la maladie notamment quand
il faut aller regarder dans les dossiers
médicaux parce que voilà seuls les
médecins sermentés la caisse d'assurance
maladie peuvent le faire ou qu'il
s'agisse de prestations
distribuées par les Caisses
d'Allocations Familiales puisque là ça
demande aussi des contrôles de terrain
très chronophages
sur la T2A alors effectivement ça n'est
qu'une partie de la des recettes des
hôpitaux on a on a à côté vous l'avez
cité toutes les dotations les migasques
etc
pour autant c'est 60 à 70 % que
représente la T2A sont évidemment
essentielles alors vous poser la
question sur la T2A de savoir si elle a
finalement si c'est elle qui est
[Musique]
potentiellement complexe ou si c'est son
utilisation qui
qui l'a rendu complexe alors c'est un
peu des deux sans doute mais c'est vrai
qu'on a fait jouer un outil initialement
conçu comme un outil de tarification
d'autres rôles et notamment un rôle en
matière de de
codage et donc de connaissances des de
l'activité médicale hospitalière qui est
extrêmement précieuse demeurant et notre
crainte d'ailleurs si la T2A venait à
disparaître totalement ce que nous
espérons pas parce que nous pensons
qu'elle a un certain nombre de vertus
serait de perdre justement ce système
d'information hospitalier qui est à nul
autre pareil et qui nous permet d'avoir
une vision panoramique de ce qui se
passe en France de manière extrêmement
détaillée et d'avoir une vision sur la
santé publique et avoir des politiques
épidémiologiques voilà en rapport avec
cette information extrêmement riche
extrêmement détaillée
[Musique]
sur les investissements immobiliers bon
c'est une question politique à laquelle
la Cour n'a pas
à répondre et donc je n'y répondrai pas
on a écouté merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente pour toutes ces informations
et les réponses aux questions et on
attend en effet avec impatience les
rapports dont vous nous avez parlé que
ce soit la T2A
l'hôpital il y a beaucoup de rapports
très intéressants et qui complète les
travaux qu'on a pu faire au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales entre
la commission d'enquête sur l'hôpital et
ses préconisations merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente merci Monsieur Merci
beaucoup